los mejores hx navideños escondidos en
los videojuegos si juegas al prólogo de
Gears of War 4 durante la Navidad y le
disparas a cinco muñecos de nieve
escondidos en el mapa podrás ver como
Papá Noel sale a echar un vistazo a la
bonita guerra que te has armado en Los
Simpson hit and Run dependiendo de la
fecha en la que juegues tu pantalla de
inicio cambiará hay una de Halloween una
de Acción de Gracias y una muy bonita de
Navidad con luces y Homero vestido de un
Santa Claus más gordo de lo usual en el
mapa Winter dog de Call of Duty debes
dispararle a este para rayos exactamente
a la medianoche para que Papá Noel salga
en su trineo Y de paso te haga una
referencia a Volver al
futuro y finalmente a pesar de que el
juego de Mad Max está ambientado en un
infinito desierto postapocalíptico a
ellos les importa un eso pues
viajando un poco podrás encontrar un
árbol de navidad bien bonito en medio de
la nada Hey que falte el agua y el
oxígeno en la tierra pero nunca la
Navidad y